Володимир Зеленський не раз запевняв, що його
головна місія - привести в українську політику
нових і порядних людей. Хто ж зрештою увійшов
до його команди, тривалий час залишалося невідомим.
Натомість серед радників фаворита перегонів
фігурують чимало відомих облич, яких складно
назвати новачками в українській політиці.
Це, зокрема, і нардеп Сергій Лещенко, який раніше
підтримував іншого кандидата у президенти -
Анатолія Гриценка. І колишній міністрів фінансів
Олександр Данилюк, який минулого тижня їздив
разом із Зеленським до Парижа на зустріч
із президентом Франції Еммануелем Макроном,
а за часів роботи в уряді здійснював націоналізацію "Приватбанку".
І екс-міністр економіки Айварас Абромавичус, який
з’явився на українській політичній арені після Євромайдану,
проте подав у відставку, заявивши про тиск на нього
людей із оточення президента.
Окрім того, нещодавно команда Зеленського
представила розширений список експертів
у ключових галузях. Приміром, інформаційною
та мовною політикою в команді Зеленського
опікується Олександр Харебін. До травня 2017 року
він працював першим заступником гендиректора
Національної телекомпанії України. До Євромайдану
очолював медіахолдинг UMH, яким тоді володів
Сергій Курченко, а ще раніше керував холдингом
Медіа Інвест Групп олігарха Сергія Тарути.
Іще одне "розсекречене" обличчя в команді
Зеленського - Володимир Шульмейстер.
За плечима в нього - робота у Нідерландах та Великобританії,
після повернення в Україну займався бізнесом.
Шульмейстер був першим заступником
міністра інфраструктури в уряді Арсенія Яценюка,
а в команді Зеленського спеціалізується
на питаннях транспорту та інфраструктури.
Водночас за податкову політику в команді фаворита
президентських перегонів відповідає Данило Гетманцев.
Він - член Європейської асоціації податкових професорів.
Спеціалізується на банківському та фінансовому праві
й викладає на юридичному факультеті
Київського університету імені Тараса Шевченка.
Під час передвиборної кампанії Володимир Зеленський
обіцяв запровадити в Україні народовладдя через референдуми.
Цими питаннями, а також запровадженням системи
електронного управління e-government,
у його команді опікується Олександр Мережко.
Він спеціалізується на питаннях міжнародного,
цивільного та міжнародного приватного права.
Місцеве самоврядування і регіональний розвиток
у команді Зеленського курує Руслан Рохов.
Він - засновник та керівник Школи мерів.
Це освітня програма з підготовки міських голів.
Балотувався на посаду мера Хмельницького та до Верховної ради.
Поки єдина жінка в команді - експертка
з правових питань Ірина Венедіктова.
Вона займалася розробкою декількох
законопроектів у освітній галузі, антикорупційній сфері.
Має власну наукову школу та була радницею низки юридичних фірм.
Чи стане хтось із цих людей високопосадовцем
за президентства Володимира Зеленського?
Цілком імовірно. Імена претендентів
на конкретні посади у його команді
обіцяють оголосити вже 19 квітня.